[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
good morning and happy football sunday
if you're recovering from a late
halloween
and you're still dressing your gardener
minshu costume
you're a legend welcome to the squad
ride presented by draftkings live in the
bleach report app my name is cabbie
richards
this rock star in the middle she's our
locksmith this is kelly stewart
and the young legend from the bay area
greg ivory
good morning and welcome this is the
show where we bet
anytime touchdowns we want locks we want
legends and we want winners only please
from you the audience we're five and two
this season so
and salute to jordan diddy aka the papa
legend who gave us the derrick henry
pick
for the squad ride last week that cash
appreciate you homie
so earlier this week we asked you on our
socials who's a lot to score touchdown
in
week eight check this collection of
ballers
i like that we have the kareem hunt pick
here versus las vegas couple of rookies
on the board jonathan taylor at detroit
t higgins versus tennessee gotta love
that we've narrowed it down to
five legendary videos we're gonna show
you and you're gonna decide our week
eight
squad ride let's take a look back at the
videos you sent earlier this week
because they are
awesome derrick henry
or stefan diggs dear henry it is
josh jacobs first touchdown julio jones
anytime touchdown
dream hot baby
[Applause]
if i were a jets fan i'd also be salty
the videos are getting better and better
and the joy of hitting
attend team parlay is only slightly less
exuberant
than getting a hoodie from our dude greg
ivory
wait how generous are you feeling my
dude wait wait cabbie so you're telling
me it's time
right now it's time
i'm in the comments giving away hoodies
uh i got jackboy37 he says kelly stewart
is the lock queen uh jack boy
kelly has been hot recently i'm gonna
have you walking away with a hoodie
uh i got johnny ball game saying
johnny ball game 77 is saying take the
browns
and the over oh johnny i don't know
about that one i like that raiders pick
i don't think i'm gonna give you a
hoodie for that take uh
cabbie i'm done in the comments but it's
back to you
okay let's get to round one uh i will
get this first
[ __ ] comes from tyler asaw
and the homies
it's time for this
week's touchdown of the week
let's go get him let's go get him let's
go get him
[Music]
take the touchdown of the week right now
pick
wait wait wait that's an impression
that's an impressive collection of
baseball caps
but what was on his roommate's laptop
though
i mean he was trying to usher them out
quickly gabby
our investigators are on it uh in the
meantime here is his first
opponent jesse bernstein
so i'm struggling between aj brown and
derek henry for anytime touchdown score
bet
so i'm gonna call the hotel front desk
and have them pick for me
hi ma'am how are you doing tonight um so
i'm in a little bit of an impasse here
uh derek henry or aj brown to score a
touchdown this weekend
um all right thank you ma'am good luck
with your parlays and all your bets may
i'll dice roll your way
she was lovely she was lovely okay
you've heard our first two pitches
uh nelson aguilera and the raiders at
cleveland or
derrick henry in the titans at
cincinnati tell us in the comments
who should move on to round two are we
riding with the
loud legend or the front desk legend
g money what do you think cabbie i'm
over here thinking about
the execution of the video with the loud
legend i mean my guy
was loud i'll give him an a for
effort though they they put a lot of
effort into it the execution er
he was just kind of loud for me now
let's talk about
the other video we received the front
desk legend this is legendary
now i've called the front desk for room
service i've called the front desk for
towels
i've also called the front desk for bed
sheets but i've never
called for a lock this video is
absolutely legendary
shout out to the front desk lady kelly
we got nelson aguilar taking on the
cleveland browns
we got derrick henry who's been ballin
and who we rode with last week
talk to me tell me what are you thinking
what a front dash call was absolutely
hilarious and i loved it
she was very definitive and that she
liked derek henry i'm really curious to
see though where she's from i need to
make sure there's no bias in her pick
i honestly don't love that game at five
and a half i was looking at tennessee
then a couple of alignment for the uh
the bengals were announced that they
wouldn't be playing the line moved to
seven
as far as the game goes that's a no play
for me but if you follow us on ig
you know i'm already on the raiders i
put them in a teaser earlier in the week
we're a little late to the party on that
one but
as far as the videos go i think it's
just
very simple here you have to take
derrick henry with that draftkings odds
boost at three to one
he's gonna score a touchdown today
cabbie caviar i'm in the comments
i'm sorry but i'm in the comments and i
got oh i see a lot of derrick harry let
me just give away some hoodies because
this is what the people is here for
boom boom ca927
says king henry i don't know if that's
deserving of a hoodie
but shout out to you now i got tanika
plan 88 says derrick henry runs over
algolar in this one
i like that take because i think that
derrick henry is going to run over
aguilar in this one well i think he's
going to score uh i got one more for you
cabbie i got
one more for you i got uh
i got maddie coop king henry over
butterfingers for sure
[Laughter]
that was what a tremendous video years
ago i think it was like a fire anyway
uh nelson aguilar hopefully he can catch
some problems from derek carr
uh today okay great start for jesse
bernstein you've survived round one but
you got to
you've got to survive three more rounds
my dude in order to be
the king of the hill and to become the
squad ride
uh in round two um
are any of you guys so kel sorry you
said you weren't gonna touch the titans
game
and you were are so you're on the the
raiders uh versus the the browns yes
yes so i gave out on ig on friday we
talked about look it's
really important when you're teasing
games you want to go through the key
numbers of
three and seven at that time the raiders
are plus two and a half so we'll get
them over a field goal over a touchdown
now the raiders are plus one so unless
you're willing to lay a little bit more
juice
you cannot get those key numbers i think
the bookmakers are pointing in a certain
direction
and it's not towards the browns cabbie
okay okay
all right we'll see how those vegas
raiders do um our next pitch
is from the pumpkin patch and colby cook
uh uh we actually hope before we get to
that um
i was uh uh as when you're
when you're on the teaser kel's uh one
more thing because i haven't made my
bets yet today and i i usually make my
bets after the show based on
what the what the audience sends us any
time touchdowns or whatever when you're
on the teaser
are you are you ever parlaying that with
another game or you just like you just
got the
three with the with the raiders so kathy
when you're doing
um what i would call mathematically
correct teasers right
you want to only do two team six point
teasers
right i get questions all the time do
you want a 13
point sweetheart teaser do you want to
do a pleaser bet all these crazy ones
keep it simple guys because the
bookmakers charge a price for each one
of those points you're getting
and points coming at a premium with six
at minus 120 is okay but after that
you're paying just a little too much
juice for the squeeze at least for my
liking
so again try to keep it simple here
again key numbers three
and seven you never want to tease
through zero and no you never want to
tease these totals especially not this
year
these totals have been absolutely
cruising over i understand
but it's not worth it because the key
numbers as far as those go
are not as valuable as the field goal
and the touchdown
thank you kels i will be locking in
right after the show we're having a
little bit of technical difficulties
so g-money uh you got any are they
showing us some love in the car not
showing us in love but are they showing
either one of these picks uh in the
comments we have nelson aguilera
and then we have derrick henry oh i
thought you want to give out to my
husband yeah
hey cabbie you know what i'm ready to do
i thought that's what i thought that's
what you was queuing me up for
uh i'll give away some hoodies and then
i'll tell you who they're riding with
i got ryan abadilla honestly have no
idea what kelly is talking about but i
believe her
he has faith in you kelly and since he
has faith in you
i'm gonna give him a hoodie for having
faith in you because that's what we do
here we ride with each other
i'm gonna keep going uh here we go
go niners 49 49 greg show some love to
the fellow niner fans
go niners 49 49 my god you know
we're taking on seattle i'm not gonna
give you a hoodie today
just check back in winter's only
wednesdays on wednesday tap in
but i'm back into the comments cabbie
i'm back into the comments
uh kp giant name a better trio in the
betting world i'll wait
let's wait for a little bit yeah they
didn't say anybody
because uh we're the best we're the best
here shout out to ukp giants you're
walking away with a hoodie
but cabbie i'm seeing a lot of derrick
henry i mean he's taken over the
comments
literally derek henry has taken over the
comments we wrote with him last week
i mean the comments are saying let's
ride with him again
i think he should be moving on here and
he is moving on with uh
jesse bernstein's pick so well done uh
to one of the comments or sometimes
when we've been working with kelly for a
couple of years and when she gets into
her zone and she's seeing those numbers
like allen from the hangover
sometimes we get lost too and she's just
deep into the math and we're just
one of these so that's why we ride with
our mvp because the information is so
legit
it's so legit uh are there any uh
all right uh we're still having uh gabby
we got we're stopping technical
difficulties i want to give out i want
to talk about the pick that i just gave
out
uh on twitter yes if you guys aren't
following at vr betting on twitter and
ig we do separate videos on each so
you're missing out you gotta be
following both
so i actually gave this one out on both
because i love it so much so
we've been talking about divisional
underdogs this year and i
understand that the denver broncos are
not an ideal team to be backing
monetarily but the denver broncos
are a divisional underdog they went from
three and a half
down to three that is a big time money
move cabbie i think a lot of people
don't understand that we were just
talking about value in terms of numbers
through a teaser this is a huge move
from that hook from three and a half to
three
nine and one on the season our
divisional home
underdogs we're rocking with the broncos
today so if you guys miss that
on twitter or ig you're late to the
party i still think you can find some
threes with our friends over at
draftkings
so jump on board it's not my best bet
you still got to wait till the end of
the show to get that one
but uh i really have started to like
that one a lot today
all right so as you guys know on this
show we like to bet on anytime
touchdowns because we love that
action let's just let's just recap some
of the players some of the most popular
picks from the week that we have on the
board
in in wiki let's just take a look real
quick we got eight of these studs
head over to draftkings if you're loving
any of those picks but more importantly
stay in the app and
and fire off your hot takes again that's
you know
we're talking about the raiders and in
the browns today that cream hunt pick is
is up there a couple of rookies okay so
uh shout out to jesse bernstein who
survives round one
still got three more to go through uh to
become
our squad ride let's get let's get you
set let's get a set
for the next pick okay round two our
next pick our next pitch
comes from the pumpkin patch with a
little alliteration there
from colby cook and an uncredited extra
fellas who was the king of the patch
[Music]
dk metcalf darren waller let's see who
breaks it home
and you're a winner dk mad cow let's
bring it home
baby great punctuation there you've
heard from the pumpkin legends
uh tell us in the comments who should
move on to round three
greg are you too young for those like
one-on-one head-to-head drills in in
football did you have those
or did they stop those by the time you
played uh popcorn no
no no cabbie we on our backs coach blow
the whistle
bang yeah i'm not too young for that
yeah we used to do that back in pop
warner when i was in high school
but uh let me talk about this oklahoma
drill
i mean i don't even know if the other
pumpkin actually uh
busted like we might have to go to
review you guys tell me in the comments
i didn't see it actually uh
bust or break or anything they might
have to run that one back but uh
he did settle with dk metcalf and one
thing say
dk has been ballin i mean we we've been
looking at his highlight
for the last week or so uh him chasing
down buddha baker
uh but kelly dk in that
seattle offense is facing you know
a team from the bay by the name of the
san francisco 49ers so just talk to me
tell me what do you see do you see him
getting in the end zone today
uh greg this one's uh really interesting
because
no disrespect to dk metcalf but he's
still wide receiver number two to tyler
locket
we're gonna see i think he might see
some double team today by that nine or
secondary
i know you missed my tweet but right
before the show started uh this niners
line dropped to two and a half we were
talking about big money moves that three
to two and a half is a big money move
as well and why we're seeing all the
tickets on the seattle seahawks yet all
the money's on the niners
what does that mean that's right we got
some reverse live movement guys
that tells me another divisional dog is
gonna keep it close today greg
you gotta sprinkle on that niners money
line my dude you gotta
sprinkle it greg who is the audience
riding with are they are they riding
with the niners the seahawks or more
importantly
for the squad rod are they riding with
dk metcalf
or is it still king henry
cabby it's back and forth in the
comments i'll be honest with you
but i got my guys z walter saying dk
about to give me a payday
since you're thinking of getting a
payday i'm thinking
of giving you a hoodie uh z walters you
are walking away
with the hoodie uh c
gal dino said niners are winning this
game seattle is overrated that is a good
take brother
kelly just said it she just said
sprinkle the
spring on the money nine i'm not gonna
give you a hoodie but i love the take
i'm back into the comments i got uh
i got tanika tanika plant 88 i'm running
with dk
metcalves uh you're walking away with a
cop i mean with a hoodie because i like
the creativity she called him met cavs
you like that right cabbie uh i mean
i think i i'm seeing a lot of dk metcalf
in the comments i i think we got a rock
with dk
all right okay pumpkin legends
you guys are moving on it's listen it's
third and goal you have two defenders
in front of you to claim the squad ride
top spot
so let's start round three next up is
the mayor
whose pitch comes to us from under
center
[Music]
ready break blue 42
omaha
[Music]
who is it who is it zeke elliott
anytime touchdown score this week it's a
lock
all right
[Laughter]
salute to the mayor oh well done
g buddy what's your take cabbie
i mean let's talk about the
execution here i mean he was under
center he even
called out the omaha the old peyton
omaha
he changed the play here threw a little
audible drop back i mean he he kind of
messed up
with his first step back but then he
picked it up dropped back and delivered
a pass to ezekiel elliott
sitting at plus 105 cabbie i mean the
cowboys don't have a quarterback
i mean all they have is zeke uh i don't
dislike this one here
love the creativity of the video keep
sending those
in please keep sending those in kelly
talk to me though
we got dk metcalf facing that niners d
and we got ezekiel elliott with no
quarterback
talk to me this is so tough greg i don't
know if you caught it in the app this
morning i was just kind of cruising
through
and there's this headline that says
should the cowboys trade zeke
what now listen i know he's got a bad
case of fumbleitis i understand but how
is my dude plus 105.
that's just downright disrespectful i do
think that it is
zeke has you know maybe toned it down
the last couple weeks maybe hasn't been
partying as much
maybe he's gonna hold on to the dang
football against their divisional rivals
in
the eagles we shall see uh
plus 105. wow with zeke that just seems
like
so shocking i do think zeke will score a
touchdown today
dk metcalf probably will also score a
touchdown but i do think he's going to
get double team so if i have to pick
here
i'm going with zeke and no as far as
this game goes kathy why is this game
still on sunday night football does
anybody have a rhyme or reason for that
great the way i'm looking at it is
should be the
ravens and the steelers that's the game
of the week it could be
the afc game of the year for all i'm
concerned
uh this is tough i i want nothing to do
with that game
other than i do think there's some great
value there on zeke
j money how are the commenters reacting
zeke elliott
dk metcalf are there some fire takes
about the eagles and
and the cowboys and gabby cabbie it's a
it's back and forth in the comments once
again i got
chris den s in saying zeke is feasting
today with no quarterback it is a lock
yes i am giving you a hoodie for
the positivity in feasting with zeke uh
i got stripling warriors saying
greg good old greg across you know zeke
is scoring zeke is the only
semi player on the cowboys right now
you called my name brother so when you
call my name you know what i do i come
running i'm going to give you a hoodie
and your take was fired zeke is the only
well i mean mari cooper's there too and
he's on my fantasy team let's not spend
the cabbie but cabbie cabbie he has to
have a quarterback throw him the ball so
you know you got to factor that in
so uh i'm loving stripling warriors take
i got one more for you cabbie
giants 1380 zeke the monster about to
carry the cowgirls into the end zone
my guy got a little creative there just
for getting a little creative with
giants 1380 i'm gonna send you a hoodie
cabbie uh it looks like zeke is moving
on him if you ask me in the comments
it looks like zeke and the qb legend is
moving on with this one
okay shout out to you the mayor the qb
legend we'll see if you'd be handing off
that
that rock to to zeke to to lead our
squad ride
in uh week eight okay so we have now
reached the final round this is the last
one
the winner of this round is our squad
ride so zeke elliott
let's go into round four and the
opponent
is shakadou and his grandma who has more
sauce than anyone on this show
who is slamming on a touchdown this week
[ __ ] kyrie killed it's a
[ __ ] luck
slam it
oh my god cabbie i think i just saw my
future
i love grandma that is absolutely
awesome
so much sauce such an o.g tell us in the
comments whether you're riding with
grandma
and the tyreek hill pick or if you're
still on ezekiel elliott
should we ride with the qb legend uh
g-money what do you think about this
particular video and grandma
tabby grams is a legend
for life i mean she kept it a buck with
us she kept it a buck she kept it a buck
she
she's an og and she kept it a buck
that's all you can do is respect that
i mean and let's talk about the pick
here though cabbie not only did she keep
it
real with us she gave us a solid pick
and tyreke
heel uh pat mahomes and the boys are
facing the jets come on the jets
you don't think that tyreke hill is
going to score here sitting at minus
139 come on that's love to me
shout out to graham's kelly talk to us
though
we got tyreek hill facing the jets
and then we got zekey elliott with no
quarterback yeah greg this is just a
really
ugly game i'll be honest with you do i
want to lay almost three touchdowns with
the chiefs
no of course not right now the chiefs
are just on cruise control
hanging out in first place in the afc
west next week they played the panthers
right now
their goal is to just hang out don't let
anybody get hurt don't anything too
crazy i think they could name the score
here
so i wouldn't be surprised to see the
back door open and somehow the jets
stay within three touchdowns but i'm not
touching this game
one thing though that is for sure
grandma nailed it tyreek hill is scoring
a touchdown today
excellent get in the comments and vote
for our winner in the meantime while you
do that
as kelly mentioned the carolina panthers
last week they covered
adding a w to the win column for kelly's
best bets
love that appreciate the cash kelly let
us know who is the lock in week 8 give
us your best bet
[Music]
cabbie it's always talked about on the
show that you don't want to overreact to
too much of what you saw last and all of
a sudden
on monday the whole world was on the 5-1
bears they couldn't wait to tell them
how much they loved them they
took the six they bet the money line and
what happened
the rams was the play the rams
absolutely dominated this team
now the stock is super low on this bears
team and i don't
understand it they're back at home they
have a top 10
defense i understand nick foles
mitch trubisky it doesn't matter who's
under center both have terrible qbr
ratings
this is too many points for the chicago
bears chicago
plus five chicago on the money line
get on get in on draftkings lock in that
lock
the chicago bear is going to need to
take advantage of that depleted new
orleans receiver core so we'll see how
that
wow shakes up thank you to our mvp kelly
stewart bears lock it in
all right greg we are ready to ride
my dude please let us know who are we
riding with what is the squad ride and
who is our new legend
in week eight cabbie i'm in the comments
and i think this is one this is
this is by a landslide i mean every
comment that i'm looking at
is rocking with grams and tyreke hill
to take this week's squad ride
apparently we're riding with tyree kill
to face the jets pat mahomes and the
boys
can i get the graphic to change for me
please can we show
the plus 300 that draftkings
is offering us uh
we're gonna ride this on the ig story
today if you guys have
locks if you guys have takes make sure
you tune in to the ig story and ride
with us we're riding tyrique against the
jets i'm feeling good right now cabbie i
don't know about you but i'm feeling
good
i feel good too and and i feel good
about shaka doe and
salute to grandma thank you very much
draftkings for the odds boost
make sure to lock in with our br socials
for the link
to the odds booths that's very important
send us your screenshots
we want winners only and send us your
videos because we love watching them and
we love featuring them
on this show hope you guys have enjoyed
that extra hour of sleep maybe we'll get
an extra hour of football and
a couple of overtime games today which
would be nice congrats to all our hoodie
winners
congrats to everybody or thank you
everybody wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait cabbie
wait wait what do we know what are we
doing no you know i cannot get out of
here
without giving away some more hoodies on
my handy dandy uh
ipad uh here we go cabbie uh voodoo
craig says lock it up with hill
then 10 times the money on bail i like
what you're doing there they are facing
the jets
and uh that's a practice squad team that
the jets have so
uh voodoo craig you're walking away with
a hoodie uh
my guy a hunt 88 says josh jacobs is
scoring two times
i have the raiders today so i like that
kelly i know that you were talking
raiders so we're riding
a hunt you're walking away with a hoodie
cabbie i got one more
josh allen goat says greg don't leave
don't leave
give me a hoodie first guess what
brother i'm here
i haven't left yet i'm still giving away
hoodies so you're walking away with a
hoodie cabbie
i think that's it thank you gregor claus
i know the audience appreciates it they
love the one hey listen we're in
november now so those hoodies
are gonna come in handy thank you to all
our legends tyler asol kobe cook
shaka doe uh jesse bernstein and the
mayor
i appreciate for hey listen every for
those who
have sent in videos and they weren't
featured you have another chance to be
legendary next week so keep sending them
in and keep leveling up
alongside kelly stewart greg ivory my
name is kevin richards thank you for
watching
the squad ride here on the bleach report
app have a have a wonderful sunday
[Music]
[Music]
you